well las vegas just got a little or
maybe a lot more fashionable i'm here
with fashion legend fashion icon dapper
dan thank you so much for being here and
thank you guys so much for having me
we're so excited to have you here at
magic in las vegas let's talk about your
involvement here and just how excited
you are to be a part of this today i am
so excited about this oh oh i've only
been to the magic
one time
and that's when of course college was
here in 1989
but and since then i have not been back
because i have a different i had a
different trajectory so this is like so
exciting for me i really feel no pun
intended i really feel the magic that
takes place here dapper dan took the
stage with fellow fashion icon elaine
welterrock for a panel discussion about
this tight-knit fashion community to
just be surrounded by this community of
fashion lovers and people who are
creating in this space is really
it's inspiring and also to do it with
dapper dan she's one of my favorite
people in fashion and one of my favorite
people on earth is really like i feel
really honored the magic trade show
ignites the magic within the field of
fashion it's just not just passion it's
the human side of it
that fashion gives us the
opportunity to show the world and elaine
welterroth welcomed fans into her world
by writing a book titled more than
enough i don't think you should wait
until the end of your life to look back
on your story i think one of the major
keys that came from our conversation was
you know
giving yourself roses along the way
while you're in that middle stage before
you've gotten to the top and also to
share your journey share your
experiences with other people um because
the middle stuff that's that's where
it's that's where the magic happens in
addition to being a new york times
bestseller elaine was named the
editor-in-chief of team vogue at age 29
making her the second person of
african-american heritage and the second
youngest in conde nast history being
able to give a platform to young people
at that time
to
talk about what mattered to them and to
you know infuse fashion into this larger
cultural conversation i think was
part of
i found a lot of purpose in that role
and finding that purpose is all about
timing be willing to walk away from one
dream to pursue the next that next dream
led her to the runway as a judge on
project runway i feel so
energized by being able to connect with
these emerging designers and
seeing their talent and being able to
give them this major platform to launch
their businesses and their careers and
i'm so excited that this season we had
an all-female
final four who were so incredibly
talented the fashion industry is
continuing to pave a path of inclusivity
showing the world that beauty comes in
all sizes shapes and colors
so that's my thing
embracing all of that
is the most exciting thing that's
happening in fashion right now
i'm